>> I WANT MY SCHOOLS
PROTECTED JUST LIKE MY BANKS
ARE PROTECTED JUST LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE.
I GET A KICK.
I WAS WATCHING A POLITICIAN
WEAK INEFFECTIVE POLITICIAN
LAST NIGHT I WILL TELL YOU
THE NAME BUT I DON’T WANT TO
EMBARRASS ANYBODY.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT NO GUNS
NO, THIS, NO THAT.
HE IS SURROUNDED BY THREE
GUYS CARRYING GUNS.
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO GIVE
UP THEIR GUNS?
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
UP THEIR GUNS BUT HE WANTS
EVERYBODY ELSE TO HAVE NO
GUNS, ALL RIGHT?
AND HAVE YOU PLENTY OF THEM.
>> Sean: THAT WAS FROM
TODAY’S LISTENING SESSION U
THAT WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
TWO DAYS IN A ROW FOLLOWING
THIS HORRIFIC MASS SHOOTING
LAST WEEK.
WELL, THE PRESIDENT HAS KNOW
SHOWN LEADERSHIP.
IS HE TRYING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS.
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS AND KIDS
SAFE.
JOINING US NOW A BIG WARM
CPAC WARMING TO THE
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT,
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, IS THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, LIKE A
LOT OF ISSUES.
EVERYBODY TALKED ABOUT
OPENING ANWR AND NOBODY DID
IT UNTIL PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
IT?
>> RIGHT.
MOVING JERUSALEM.
>> Sean: EVERYONE TALKED
ABOUT.
>> OUT OF PARIS.
>> Sean: NOBODY DID IT SINCE
DONALD TRUMP.
IS HE GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITH SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
>> I BELIEVE CAN HE AND HE
WILL.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE
GRATEFUL THAT DONALD J.
TRUMP IS THE PRESIDENT AT
THIS TIME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THE UNITED STATES, TO HOLD
BACK-TO-BACK SESSIONS
YESTERDAY AND TODAY, TODAY
PUBLIC SAFETY, SCHOOL SAFETY
WITH ELECTED OFFICIALS, WITH
COMMISSION COMMISSIONERS OF
THE POLICE THE SHERIFFS AND
EDUCATORS YOU HAVE THE MAYOR
OF PARK LAND, FLORIDA HAS
BEEN A REMARKABLE WOMAN
THROUGHOUT THIS.
FOR HIM TO DO THIS YESTERDAY
AND TODAY.
AND YESTERDAY TO HAVE THE
PARENTS THERE INCLUDING
THOSE WHO SUFFERED LAST WEEK